ladies and gentlemen i'm ryan right and
I am Jerry welcome to reasons to see
where we give you reasons to see and not
to see side effects so let's hang out
Ryan's consensus side effects is the
reason to see side effects side effects
is the reason to see side effects yeah
this film is just absolutely amazing I
completely loved it Jerry's consensus
side effects is the reason movies like
side effects will continue to be made
side effects is the reason why movies
like side effects will continue to be
made yeah man I dug this movie quite a
bit I don't love it but I did dig it
quite a bit I thought they did a good
job well I love it reason to see number
one Jude Law jus log really helps to
elevate this already terrific movie he
has such a demanding role of a
psychiatrist who's thrown into an
unexpected situation where the average
man must keep keep his cool and would
probably need therapy for something like
what you law is going through so it's
interesting to see the role reversed
where it's a psychiatrist who is on the
verge of a breakdown and he's the one
who probably needs some serious therapy
yeah so needs to lay down the law that
you'd love the Jude look it's like in
the first half of the film he keeps
everything grounded you're like oh thank
god you're here and then in the second
half of the phone it flips out and makes
you wonder if he's crazy he portrays
that obsessive level to such a strong
degree that it makes the audience wonder
if we can trust him I loved him in the
second half because as the plot
escalates so do his emotions his range
of emotions to portray in this film and
a lot of that requires so much restraint
and he does a good job with that and
he's fantastic at it because he's not
going out there being some explosive
actor because a person in his situation
would have to internalize everything so
Jude Law makes the perfect choice on
internalizing the chaos to land on law
the Jude Law Jude Law one of the main
things I loved about him because Allah
man I've been to therapy I've been to
psychiatry the main thing that I really
liked about him was how authentic he was
as a therapist not just like the
dialogue in the
he was running but his portrayal of a
therapist was seemed like a very
authentic portrayal reason to see number
two Rooney Mara if I ever meet you I
want to have sex with you like right
away I don't I'm still mad at you for
what you said about Nightmare on Elm
Street I will ask for your hand in
marriage she's just so beautiful i love
that five second sex scene with her yeah
no sex and not just her looks and the
sex but also I mean she's actually
really good in the fifth yeah her
portrayal of a woman suffering with
depression and probably post traumatic
stress disorder is so authentic that it
pulls you into this sort of Sir
realistic realm in a way feels like
you're watching a person not an actor
actors are people right you know this
woman starts off sad and then she just
spirals off into depression and then
just utter chaos yeah you know the
evolution of her character is like what
you said you know it's very authentic
it's strange because you feel bad for
her but at the same time she's also kind
of scary yeah that's true she is sort of
like the antagonist in a way because she
is the one taking the pills the side
effects seemed to be the cause and her
unpredicted actions seem to be the
effect so do we fear her or should we
fear the side effects or should we fear
jude law for prescribing these drugs
like who do we really fear her and all
the fear seems to be going to hurt this
is a movie with a lot of twists turns
character details and thrills that are
felt in large part due to rooney Mars
performance and you lost performance as
well you know way they play off each
other it is is greatness what movie
hinges on hmm is [ __ ] muttering she's
okay reason to see number 3 the
directing and writing what a brilliant
[ __ ] movie I love how Steven
Soderbergh allows the camera to just
keep on rolling with his actors and
allows that to be the major contribution
to what makes the suspense work so well
in this film rather than doing a bunch
of cheap Hollywood [ __ ] tricks and
stuff in cliches it's a movie that could
have been formulaic but it certainly
defies that you know it's good at luring
you into into trusting people and then
forcing you to question all of them at
the same time so then nothing feels safe
and no character feels fully like a good
guy or a bad guy it also explores some
some actually some really interesting
territory just in terms of the
pharmaceutical industry and it's like
who's to blame when something goes wrong
you know is it the patient or is it the
doctor who prescribed it or is it the
actual people who make the drugs and it
what's so cool about that is it doesn't
force you to pick a side and it doesn't
ram a message down your throat but it
does sort of display these these real
questions in a cool way the word I keep
using is authentic and that is the best
way to describe this film is just
authentic not just what this details on
its characters because it does feel like
you're peering into people's personal
lives from psychiatry to therapy to like
drug reps the hospitalization rolls all
of it is just this world is just so damn
authentic and I briefly mentioned it
before but the details of the characters
very impressive you know you get to
learn their internal struggles you get
to learn of their desires and you see
their development and as the plot
escalates it's not just smartly directed
but it's brilliantly written reason to
see number for cinematography I
absolutely adore the imagery in this
film from the opening frame to the next
of the next of the next there's like a
story in the cinematography itself it
seems to be a reflection of like Rooney
Mara's dark emotions an expression of
that you know I think part of what works
so well about this film is that
everything feels sort of tonally unify
unified and a big part of that is the
cinematography you know films got this
very desaturated color palette
everything's kind of washed out and then
play a lot with you know focus and stuff
there's lots of like shallow focus and
really long shots to make you feel
removed and detached it's a great visual
approximation of what a depressive state
feels like which I thought was really
cool it was like shot and depress Oh
vision reason to see number 5 the score
first Skyfall man now rocking his carpet
side effects and the than the other
ninety movies he's scored two it's the
same thing I touched on before you know
the score really supports that air of
depression that the film has
and I just thought that you know that
the sounds cuz it is varied you know
some of it is a little more that
synthesizer e but you know there's some
sort of more natural instruments and
there's some just more sort of tonal
noise and there's a lot of really cool
stuff that draws you in to both the the
thriller e mystery side and just the
depressive dramatic side true so good on
you Tom Tom Newman tell Randy what's up
subscribe subscribe please subscribe
being a fan of us and tell us your
reasons to see or not to see side
effects yeah side effects of subscribing
may include you having fun mmm-hmm
seeing more videos supporting us so we
can make more videos for you itchy palms
dry mouth insomnia suicidal thoughts or
actions don't operate heavy machinery
while watching reasons to see don't
watch reasons to see if you've had more
than one alcohol today um if you're
already taking a movie review show
consult your doctor before adding
reasons to see to your review regimen
[ __ ] yeah and tuck your talk to your
doctor and subscribe talk to you so we
prescribe that you subscribe to this we
prescribe more videos
you